about three years ago i was interviewed
by
uh the economist and we were talking
about aggression
and i said that men are
on average more aggressive than women or
they're more physically aggressive
so among children for example boys are
more likely to kick
hit bite and steal and that's not a bad
operationalization of aggression let's
say and then if you look within boys
a small proportion of the boys are that
way
at two most of them get socialized out
of it but those that don't
are stably anti-social and criminal into
the adolescence and adulthood
and then that burns out around 28
that's the developmental trajectory of
aggression doesn't look like it's
learned okay so however there's
something else so that's interesting
enough it's like
it's there at two it's a rage circuit
it's an old old biological circuit and
it gets controlled and most aggressive
kids are socialized by the time they're
four and if they're not you can't
socialize them after that that's also
very interesting and rather
disheartening
but women girls however they are more
aggressive than males
if you measure aggressive aggression
differently
they use reputation destruction
so well we've seen what happens with
social media
physical aggression doesn't translate to
but reputation destruction
that translates to social media
unbelievably well
so maybe it's time to have a little chat
about toxic femininity
well there we go jordan i've got a
little piece of paper here with some of
the questions we were going to ask you
and the next one on my list is why do
people hate you
uh i think you've answered that what
why do you think why do you think well i
was gonna ask you this
what would you point to well let me ask
you this because i think this is an
important part of it
uh helen lewis who's interviewed you and
who's who wrote a review of your book
who she hates me yeah she hates you
i've met helen lewis and she's
interviewed me
and of all the things you might say
about her you wouldn't say that she was
stupid
and you wouldn't say that she was poorly
educated right
so i might say that
i was being jealous she took advantage
of the education that was offered to her
but yeah but but but education is so
corrupt
that mastering it makes you an expert at
nonsense
touche touche i like sabda but let's
just go with the she's intelligent point
so she should be able to understand your
arguments and i'm sure she does
and yet i noticed time after time where
an intelligent person even kathy newman
you wouldn't say that she's stupid
and lots of others come after you with a
vitriol
and a visceral you can feel it
you can when you want to be there yeah
right well when i went to the gq
interview yeah
look i've got to say when i went to the
kathy newman interview
kathy newman was very professional we
met in the green room beforehand she was
perfectly polite um in a professional
sort of way you know but that's fair
enough professional politeness beats the
hell out of you know random rudeness
so i'll take it um when i walked into
the gq
interview and and this was i was already
pretty worn out
at that point um there was a photo shoot
first and
then the interview and that place was
hostile
right from the moment i walked in and so
i'm kind of on edge in that interview
because i could feel that and it was
like
um the stage was set long before i
walked into that
so there wasn't even professional
politeness it was
you know people can freeze up a room
some people are really good at that
i think maybe it has to do with smell
you know i lived with someone once and
you could tell if they were upset when
you walked into the house you'd get kind
of an uneasy feeling and
the only explanation i have for that is
that it's related to smell at some
unconscious level
in any case the gq
interview atmosphere was unbelievably
tense
and i was sort of in there for 45
minutes before i started talking so i
was
you know i was already in the position
of a cat who hears dogs barking down the
street
so um in any case
it still isn't obvious to me
what it is that causes such animosity
well let me posit a theory jordan
because this is what i really wanted to
ask you you tweeted the other day when
helen lewis
published a review of your book you said
why do you hate me i've tried to be a
good man
and i replied saying i think you've
answered your own question
and my fear is and my question to you is
do you think that fundamentally you
mentioned toxic feminine
i don't like to get into this whole
gender thing in that way because
the whole gender war is a stupid thing
to me as far as i'm concerned but
i do think it's possible that we live in
a society where some people
those people that i'm talking about they
they hate they don't want strong men
they don't want
men to be better they want men to be
weaker
and they see you as an agent of change
who helps men to be better and they are
scared of that
well
if you've had bad experiences with men
and you know that's probably the
universal female experience
right because we all fall short of the
ideal
and of course that's deeply
disappointing to women just as women who
fall short of the ideal
are deeply disappointing to men but
let's say you've had
less than ideal relationships perhaps
with any man in your life
it might make it very difficult for you
to distinguish between authority and
power right because
if authority is misused it looks like
power and misused power is tyranny
and so the best thing to do
in the case of misused power is to
reduce the power
and if authority incompetence never
enter the issue never enter the
the question then you don't ever think
you're sacrificing something you're just
dampening down the possibility of
tyranny this is partly why i
i the oppressive patriarchy narrative is
so dis
distasteful to me it's like look fair
enough you know i mean
every hierarchical system has
its tyrannical aspect and you might say
well let's get rid of hierarchies it's
like
no sorry you can't even see
without a hierarchy because you have to
decide what you're going to look at and
you privilege what you're looking at
over all the things you aren't looking
at and you produce a value hierarchy
instantly there's no escape from that
unless you could equally attend to
everything all the time
which you can't so you're stuck with
hierarchies
there's no escape from them that doesn't
mean they're universally benevolent
because they're not
and they get warped by power but just
because they get warped by power doesn't
mean that that's their essence
authority is their essence and that's
competence right
and but if you can't distinguish those
two
well then it's all out of salt on
anything that looks like power
so and there's definitely there's
there's a huge element of that it's so
unfortunate because you see then that
boys get punished for their ambition
you know and because that looks like the
route to power i knew
i had friends who were so guilty about
their ambition
that well in one case it killed him
he committed suicide now he had his
problems you know but
one of them was that he was unbelievably
guilty
about being white about being an
oppressor about
about any human activity because he
associated that with the despoiling of
the planet
and it's not like we don't hear that
story over and over and over